hey before we get into our super cool
show we'd like to thank salesforce for
sponsoring a portion of this episode
salesforce essentials is the out of the
box crm
built and priced to help small
businesses adapt to evolving customer
needs
in an ever increasing digital work from
anywhere world
salesforce essentials makes it possible
to tap into the power of salesforce
to build stronger customer relationships
with crm
and customer support for small business
that is
easy to use set up and maintain
look you probably spent a good bit of
your life and energy making that website
and you did a great job now make it even
better
allowing your site to work harder for
you by leveraging
lead capture in salesforce right
on your site you'll be able to generate
new business
and develop relationships with customers
from your crm
let's say you want to share a special
promo
or create a vip list and then message
them
salesforce essentials can help you send
messages
to a specific list of recipients getting
as broad
or as targeted as you'd like up your
customer service by creating a help
center page
making it easy for patrons to find
information
themselves or meet them where they are
and better assist them
by connecting your email phone and
social channels click the link below and
check out the website for yourself
you will not be sorry and thanks again
to salesforce
for sponsoring a portion of this show
chuck hey got another one for you all
right
um these are never ending just so you
know that's a good thing
okay they're always always entertaining
so i'm i'm anxious to see what we're
gonna talk about now
all right so advice for life you ready
okay never
never wish your astronomy friends
an evening of twinkling stars really
yeah so what what is the problem with
it's a big problem
all right but if and it's it's even made
it into the song
right twinkle twinkle little how i
wonder
what you are what you are of course i
never sang that song because i know what
stars are
right that's that's a pre-scientific era
lyric were you were you uh
a preschool neil degrasse tyson and
heard this little nursery rhyme and how
i wonder what you are and it's just like
i'll tell you what it is
i mean this this really isn't that tough
guys
okay it's a big ball of plasma
okay so but anyhow the twinkle is it's a
it's a romantic
concept right because it's not just a
pinpoint of light it actually
uh sparkles in some way yeah and we like
sparkly objects right
and in fact the very word sparkle
implies that it's constantly changing
right right so here's what's going on
the stars are
as large as they are right like the sun
take it as a sort of a middle-sized star
if it was hollowed out you could pour a
million earths
into it and still have room left over
wow
it's huge it's big it's big it's big
and it's not even a big star it's not
even
it's like it's that is huge and it's not
even a big star it's
right they get bigger some get as big as
the size of earth's
orbit oh my gosh yeah yeah so now you
want to talk big we talk big
so uh that's the problem if you're
writing an astronomy book
you exhaust your adjectives very
your superlative adjectives it's like
this was a massive planet
right well isn't the star a thousand
times more massive okay it was a massive
star
right the black hole this was a massive
part super duper super
massive right right exactly yeah so you
got to like apportion your adjectives in
my field
so here's here's the thing as big as
stars are they are
so far away that they're basically just
pinpoints of light
from this distance all right and i can i
actually did a calculation
that i might tweet one day to to give
you a sense of how far away stars are
all right
so if you shrink the sun down
to a to the size of the period that ends
a sentence
in a book okay so that's the side make
that the size of the sun so everything
sort of shrinks
so that that's true okay you can ask how
far away is the nearest star
okay how far away is the universe star
four miles away
four miles away yes if the sun is if the
sun is that big
that's correct that's a really long way
away space is empty
empty freaking empty okay so
that's a whole other conversation empty
spaces i mean
i'm picturing that you you're it's it's
it's a it's a period
we're talking about yes i mean that's
and that is
four miles away from the next from the
next star
so stars are not accidentally bumping in
the night okay that's crazy crazy that's
a
crazy distance man space is big
and space is empty okay wow okay
all right it's hard to get over
it's actually i mean seriously because
when you're i gotta go
for it when you make that scale in your
brain when you're making that scale
in your brain it's it's kind of
overwhelming you're like wait a minute
i got another one for you the thing i go
like this end of sentence
now take that thing and put it four
miles away from me
that's the closest start that's insane
man
yeah go ahead go ahead it's completely
insane yes yes
okay here's another one ready so if this
is the
the earth you know the size of a school
room globe like how far away is the moon
where would you put it okay most people
would put it like you know maybe a
couple of feet away
because that's how they see it drawn in
books exactly you see earth on the left
side and then the moon
no it's 30 feet away so
it's not even in the same room it's not
in the same room because you couldn't
fit it in the book
okay all right so here's an interesting
fact and i don't
take credit for first coming up with
this reference you ready
if you take all the planets okay
if you position them adjacent to one
another
right you can fit all planets
in the gap between earth and the moon
that's how far away the moon is from
earth oh my god
that's that's pretty big man yeah
jupiter is ten times as wide as earth is
and so is saturn basically yeah
you just line all these up you can fit
them all easily between the earth moon
just so i'm just saying let me get back
to twinkling stars so let's get back to
twitter it starts
all right so space is space is super big
and super empty basically is what we
just found out
it's a point of light so here is a
perfect point of light
okay that's traveled who knows how long
okay depending if it's near us or on the
other side of the galaxy
or across the universe it is a point of
light
okay a stream of photons coming down
right then it hits our atmosphere
so in this last part of this long
journey that these photons took
it's got to get through the air to get
to your eyeball
right okay and the air has many
different
temperature layers okay there's
something called the thermosphere up
there where the sun's
energy is absorbed by ozone and the
temperature goes up
in that section of the atmosphere below
that the temperature is dropping
okay and it drops continuously until you
get to that layer
not only that the ground is not evenly
heated
by the sun because some areas reflect
light like the the water and snow
and other places absorb light like dark
areas and so
so so that that heats the air
at different rates so these pockets of
air
that have different why does hot air
rise why does hot air rise
uh because it's lighter it's lighter
it's less dense right that's what you're
going to say because it's hotter
that's enhanced hot air rises okay
because it's hotter
so hot air expands becomes less dense it
becomes more buoyant and it rises
okay and for every pocket of air that
rises it doesn't leave a vacuum
down there what happens some other
pocket of air takes its place
okay so you get what's called convection
all right
on a kitchen stove it's called boiling
all right but convection is
you heat down here it rises up it drops
back whole pockets of air
are moving all right this is going on
all the time
all over earth's atmosphere okay okay
now hold that aside for a moment have
you ever been in a hot desert
climate and you have the and you have
the road the road is probably darker
than the sands that surround it
right because it's asphalt or whatever
or so a darker
form of it probably don't use asphalt
because it it gets too hot in the summer
but whatever it is
it's dark okay if you drop down low
in mid afternoon summer and look you see
this sort of
way wavy the wavy gravy of summer heat
the weight oh i like that chuck they're
very poetic of you
the wavy gravy of summer heat and so
this is the
this is the origin of mirages right
because the way
the light the way this uh these
turbulent layers of heat
mess with the air it makes you think
there's a pocket of water there
that you think is an oasis we're saved
okay so uh
we're safe and it's a no it's a water
fountain right no no way
so so there you are experiencing this at
this level and that's
clearly completely wreaking havoc with
your image
and what i'm saying is that is happening
over 100 miles stretch into earth's
atmosphere
but on a smaller level okay because it's
not that hot
as you get higher up but it's not as
small as a pocket of air here
pocket of air there so the light comes
down
and as the light comes down it goes into
a slightly cooler pocket of air
if you go from one density of air to
another air the light
bends it refracts because it's going
between two different densities
this is what happens when a straw is
bent coming out of your glass of water
does anyone still use straws all right
um it's bent because
the air has a different pathway of light
than the water does okay it bends all
right so and i'm not talking about a
bendy straw
i'm talking about a straight straw not a
crazy straw
not a crazy store no it's great i love
crazy stores when i was a kid
who does anyone oh no they're still
around
they're still not okay i love crazy
stores i i drink out of them all the
time
especially if i'm at a very fancy
restaurant i'm like please and your kids
are saying
damn right i'm like i'd like a manhattan
and please with a crazy straw
so you need james bond doing that right
a bit martini shaking not stirring
that's pretty funny and then he goes out
to his tricycle
but anyhow so what happens is
this light is refracting its way
through the atmosphere one pocket of air
at a time
of different density and the act of
doing this in fact these
air pockets are moving it means when you
try to see where the star
is the actual
the the point of light that hits your
eye at any moment is always changing
it's jumping around it's jumping around
oh man that sucks
and so the net effect is that it
sparkles
now if you take a time photo of it
timeless so in astronomy we always take
photos that last a long time
to to build on the light what happens is
the star is moving around
during the photo so by the time you're
done
the star is this blurred blob in your
image
oh man now i get it that's why you guys
hate twinkling stars
we hate twinkling stars we
hate it and so uh it has forced us to be
really clever
so let's go back to isaac newton isaac
newton said i wonder if you put a
telescope on the top
of a mountain where the air is clear
and calm whether you get better views of
the night sky i think i knew
you should be putting telescopes on
mountaintops and they're still there to
this day
to this day all the observatories are on
big mountaintops
because most of that turbulence is
happening right at the ground level
there's some happening way up
you can't avoid that but a lot is
happening at ground level so first you
go to a mountaintop
that gets you away from most of the
ground that had been around you
okay then you're above other turbulent
layers of weather
they're mauna kea in hawaii 14 000 feet
they're
half the time they're clouds beneath
them all right
they're above the low cumulus cloud
layers that often
are delivering sort of summer rains or
you know uh afternoon
um you know rain showers you know those
temporary rain showers
that's a height above where those clouds
hang out so
not only do you get clear skies because
you're above many the clouds often you
get stable skies all right now you see
so
so and by the way we have a uh a noun
we borrowed a verb and made a noun of it
it's called seeing
okay seeing how good is your seeing on
this mountaintop and you want that
number to be as small as possible
right it's how much you couldn't go with
sight you just don't know
see you can just do sight it's an
official term look it up it's my people
we can't wait it's our turn
all right seeing is how sharp is the
image
that you're looking at all right so now
um so you go to mountaintop the seeing
is much better
but it's still not perfect okay so
we tried to figure out is there a way
to track this refraction of the star
so that we can compensate for this so we
we put some of our top people working on
it
then i forgot what year was it 1993 i
forgot the year
we're at a conference and somebody who
worked for the military
said oh by the way here's how you
correct for that
it had just been declassified and so we
now have a mechanism
by which we can track these pockets of
air moving above the telescope
and once we track it we communicate that
information
to a telescope mirror that is flexible
and we distort the mirror to compensate
for the moving around of the star image
so chuck we have a term for it's called
adaptive optics
adaptive adaptive you know how we do it
you know how we do it okay we do it
ready
okay volume we take we take a laser beam
that excites sodium atoms this is one
way to do this there's
there's a layer of sodium atoms up high
in the atmosphere we take a laser beam
it excites them
and then they when you excite an atom
and then it de-excites it emits light
right so we create an artificial star
in the atmosphere above these layers
and we know exactly what this laser beam
path should look like right and as the
laser beam moves it communicates this
information
to the mirror the mirror deforms and it
undistorts the star image and you get
perfect
spots of starlight you know what i am
never going to complain when somebody's
taking too long to take a picture of me
again
what oh you think they're they're
they're adjusting the optics
yes exactly they're just using adaptive
optics that's all
yes wow so here's an interesting fact
that got so good and it beca it came of
age in the
in the 1990s that the hubble telescope
which the primary reason for launching
it
into the atmos above the atmosphere was
so that it wouldn't have seeing problem
right that was the main reason right
it's just a regular optical telescope
that we have here on earth's surface
but we put it in so that we don't have
the smearing blurring
once we were able to compensate for that
on earth
the singular advantage of the hubble
telescope was diminished
we couldn't do quite as well as hubble
but we did really well
compared to hubble and compared to
before we had the hubble up there
wow so so that's the story of
seeing and the twinkling of stars
look at that that's that's super cool
that's i mean that's really that's
really cool i mean
except for the fact that you kind of
make scientists sound just a little
jaded when you say we hate twinkling
stars
okay okay okay how about this how about
this let's
just put this to bed once and for all
the song twinkle twinkle little star
how i wonder what you are up above the
sky so bright not this is like
the star light star bright no no no
sorry i'm getting them confused
what's the other one that recitation
highlights star bright first star i see
tonight and i forget the rest of it i
wish i weighed
i wish i may i wish i might something
something that start right go ahead okay
i don't know
that's the one i'm talking about not the
twinkling star that one
the first star you see tonight is
generally not a star
right it's a planet because the planets
are brighter than stars
because they're closer and they're
reflecting the scenes they're much
closer and they reflect and they're not
intrinsically brighter but they're like
sitting in our own backyard
so if you had been making wishes on
these first star you see tonight and it
hasn't been coming true it's because you
were wishing on planets
oh that's see that timmy you're really
just a dummy timmy if you knew anything
about a straw astronomer
astronomy you wouldn't be so stupid to
wish on a planet
is timmy the universal name of a little
kid jimmy
exactly little timmy sorry timmy
you wish your wish can't be you ain't
coming to you tonight
you're too stupid to know you're wishing
on the planet
and so one last thing before we gotta
land this plane
so because if you look through a
telescope the planet
shows up as a disc you can see saturn's
rings you can see
weather bands on on on on
jupiter you can see the phases that
venus goes through
it turns out that the blurring the
the twinkling is in effect primarily
because the
dot of light is moving around and
sparkling in different spots and you see
this all as
a as a twinkling spot on the sky
with a planet that can happen within the
disk of the planet
but you're not going to notice the
planet changing brightness significantly
because it's all happening sort of
within the disc itself
so this is why you may have heard if
it's not twinkling
it's probably a planet okay
so that's true most of the time so look
up at night if it's twinkling
and you see something else that's not
twinkling put your money on that one as
the plan
that's the planet okay that's cool man
that's that's good to know
so that's more than you ever care to
know about twinkling stars i don't know
i might i might still have a few
questions
no you don't because there's nothing
left yeah right
exactly all right we gotta call it quits
there chuck all about twinkling stars
and i hope you don't have any other
questions on this for the rest of your
life
there you go all right another
star talk explainer video neil degrasse
tyson
keep looking up